هناك قدر إضافي من الشجاعة هنا
لا يمكنك أن ترى أن
دنيس تقوم بطبيبة أسنان لمدة خمسة
أشهر من الإصابة بفيروس كورونا في ساو باولو ،
وهي ليست مهمة تنظيف
أفواه مصابة
مثل أي شخص يعيش هنا بعيدًا عن
وفاة أسرتها من
حولها يوميًا لكنها الأولى
أول برازيلية يتم إعطاؤها لقاحًا تجريبيًا
من جامعة أكسفورد
تحمل آمالنا جميعًا في
أن هذا اللقاح الأوفر حظًا
يعمل كمتطوع هو فعل
محب تقول إن
التبرع بقليل من نفسك
تم تقديم جميع الموظفين هنا  إذا كانوا يريدون
المشاركة
في تجربة لقاح أكسفورد ، ووضعهم
على خط المواجهة الآخر ، فإن
مطاردة العالم العاجلة للمناعة من هذا
المرض ،
كانت موضوعًا واحدًا ، وكان رئيسها
فلافيا تقريبًا يتعرض لألف في
قلوبهم ذكرى زميل طبيب كنت
صديقي لمدة 23 عامًا
يعمل هنا لمدة 23 عامًا ، أنا آسف جدًا ،
نعم لقد
كان عامًا كان سيئًا للغاية ،
عيونهم تخون الإرهاق ،
لكنهم ما زالوا هنا  ما تركوه
من تجربة اللقاح يحتاج إلى المزيد من الأشخاص مثلنا
المعرضين لخطر أكبر
للتلوث.إن الابتعاد عن الأشخاص الذين تحبهم أمر
صعب للغاية
عبر ساو باولو ، هناك سباق بين
القوى
المحتدمة في واحدة من أكثر المدن تضررًا على
وجه الأرض
حول من يمكنه إثبات  أولاً ، أن
لقاحهم يعمل ،
أرسلت الصين الأسبوع الماضي لقاحها السينمائي
للتجربة هنا
بين عمال الخطوط الأمامية في المدينة ، لكن
طرحه قوبل بحاجز هامشي غاضب
لما يسمونه اقتبسًا من
الفيروس الصيني ، وكذلك حديدي
في لقاح الصين هناك مخاوف
بين  موظفوك هنا من أجل
سلامة الأشخاص الذين يشاركون في
هذا بسبب الخطاب اليميني ،
هذا هو الشاغل الأول الذي
قد يتفاعل بعض الأشخاص بشكل غريب
في هذه الأيام مع متطوع
شارك
في لقاح تم
تصوره في
شركة صينية هي  هي مع
طبيبة والدتي ستيفاني تاشيرا بورتو
هي التجربة الصينية الوحيدة التي تم
نشرها للجمهور حتى الآن
، وهذا هو الجزء السهل من وباءها المؤلم.
في الأشهر الماضية ، كنت
قلقة حقًا ، لقد
بكيت كثيرًا بينما لم تكن لديها أي
تهديدات منذ أن تلقيت ضربة بالكوع هنا
، تقول إنها قد حذرت من خلال
المحاكمة لتتوخى الحذر ، وأخبروني
ألا أفضح الأمر كثيرًا وأن أحاول
عدم إخبار الجميع كيف ستكون هذه الدراسات ،
أليس هذا غريبًا ، نعم
إنه غريب جدًا من كل
ذلك ،
لا أفهم لماذا يكرهون الصين
كما لو أن هذا لم يكن
كافيًا ، فالأمريكيون يأتون مزارعين عملاقة
فايزر  تتطلع إلى اختبار
لقاحها الذي دفعت الولايات المتحدة 1.9 مليار
دولار
مقابله في نقطة ساخنة في مدينة ضخمة في البرازيل ،
ونأمل أن يكون
كل شيء أولًا أن يجد البرازيل تريد الحصول على
لقاحهم في المقابل
ويشعرون جميعًا بالحرارة والألم
في الأشهر المقبلة